one of the deserts most deadly hunters
is on the prowl it can grow up to seven
feet long and comes equipped with long
fangs capable of delivering a potent
venom the western diamondback
rattlesnake about 30 species of
rattlesnake live in the Western
Hemisphere rattlesnakes are pit vipers
so-called because of the heat sensing
pits located on either side of their
heads these helpless makes locate prey
even in the dead of night but they're
even better known for the hiss of their
famous tails
one quick rattle and any predators
instantly know to stay away far away the
rattlesnake also has a potent sense of
smell but it doesn't just follow its
nose the forked tongue picks up odor
particles from the air as it flicks in
and out and passes them over an organ in
the roof of the mouth but essentially
both smells and tastes this snake has
sniffed out the perfect place for an
ambush
with one strike
the rattlesnake injects toxic venom into
the rat which attacks the bloodstream
soon the rat is immobilized and dinner
is served rattlesnakes swallow their
prey whole slowly digesting the food as
it moves through the body an adult
rattler will generally eat only once
every two weeks which is good news for
the remaining local rodents